All of us at The School of life would like
to thank you, from the bottom of our hearts
for helping us reach 3 Million subscribers.
It is fascinating to think that there are
now more people subscribed to this channel
than there are residents of Jamaica. The entire
population of Fiji could subscribe three times
each and there would still be more of us left
over. Together you have watched over a billion
minutes of The School of Life. Thank you for
subscribing to our channel, watching our films,
exploring the big questions and growing our
collective emotional intelligence.
This channel wouldn't exist with your support,
your comments, likes and purchases in our
shop all mean that we can keep sharing what
we love with you.
To say thank you for all your support, we would like to
to give away some of our best holiday gifts,
our Great Thinkers Set, our Relationships
Set and our Calm Set. To be in with a chance
of winning one of these you simply have to
like this video, subscribe to our channel,
turn on notifications and comment below which
gift you would like. A winner will be chosen
at random and we will contact you in your
YouTube inbox to give you the good news.
From everyone at The School of Life we thank
you. Your support means the world to us.